your pal
where is he going uh
the finished probably started and this
time
none of you
that structure in the center of the city
it's a forerunner ship
and truth is heading straight for it if
he leads the covenant fleet to earth
they won't stand a chance you have to
stop him
that brood has the index and miranda and
johnson
he can activate the ring if he does i'll
detonate in amber clad's reactor just
like we did the autumns the blast will
destroy this city and the ring
it's not a very original plan but we
know it'll work
no i don't want to chance a remote
detonation
i need to stay here
flood-controlled drop ships are touching
down all over the city
that creature beneath the library that
grave mind
you stuff an amber clad was always its
intended vector
there's a conduit connecting this tower
to the ship and back inside i'll lead
you to it
uh
[Music]
uh
i'll disable this lift once you reach
the top that'll slow them down
i hope
shall we let the flood consume our holy
city
turn high charity into another of their
wretched eyes
no enemy has ever withstood our might
floods too shall
fighting fail our covenant construct is
unusually formidable
foreign
uh
[Music]
[Music]
what
foreign
oh
[Music]
uh
the parasite did not defeat the
foreigners
and it shall not defeat us
american creature
your deaths will be instantaneous
while we shall suffer the progress of
infinity systems
is
apparently these are the prophet
hierarchs their inner sanctum
this crisis will not be the end of us
it is
i'm running out of options chief i can't
stall the launch sequence much longer
the next lift will take you up to the
conduit hurry
the history of the arbiter is one of
both legend
and infamy their name has been corrupted
by great shape though the contemporary
is perhaps the most confounding of all
fel vadamy was born of noble blood
the legendary house of vada his family's
renowned demanded great expectations for
his military career
and he would meet them all
one of the youngest to achieve the
status of shipmaster
and one of the youngest to gain the rate
of supreme commander
in our campaign against the humans few
have risen to renown
as vladimir world after human world
all laid low for the sake of the great
journey
but then came halo shame untouched
he failed his greatest charge and the
sacred ring was desecrated
by such disgrace del vadomi became the
arbiter
as a mere scribe i do not challenge the
word of the hierarchs
but i would be remiss not to voice
concern
this sangheili should have been put down
publicly slain as an example to all
of our prayerful expediency
[Music]
with the discovery of a second ring and
the changing of the guard
all things are in jeopardy will this
arbiter
remain loyal or will he stand with his
people as they are abolished by our
newfound
might i would never openly challenge the
divine proclamations of a hierarch
but this arbiter is a risk i would not
have tolerated
and i now fear the days of the covenant
[Music]
i knew the covenant was good at
repurposing forerunner technology but
this
is amazing they've been using the
forerunner ship's engines as an energy
source for the city
the ship isn't so much launching as it
is disengaging
uncoupling itself from high charities
power grid
stopping truth that's all that matters
you know the plan you've got to stop
truth i've got to handle the index
[Music]
chief when you get to earth good luck
after i'm through with truth
go make a girl a promise if you know you
can't keep it
you